toujours à propos de la rentrée des
classes cette particularité en france le
taux de scolarisation en maternelle à de
rares exceptions près regarder les
chiffres
tous les enfants de trois ans 100 % vont
en classe on estime même que 30% sont
scolarisés dès 2 ans de l'avis des
experts l'enfant a tout à y gagner
mallory aoun ou diane richard un si gros
chagrin des dessins est finie charles
sait que sa maman doit partir quant au
papa il cherche comment s'en sortir
les jeux les brames c'est mieux pour
très pratique conformément à cette
équipe ce plus vite
ils sont confiants
j'avais fait beaucoup de bien d'être un
petit peu avec deux enfants fin des
activités à apprendre apprendre la vie
en collectivité je pense que ces
événements soient démarrer dans la vie
un privilège français 27 % des enfants
sont scolarisés dès 2 ans la
quasi-totalité un an plus tard un
nouveau monde pour apprendre avec et au
milieu des autres
dès le plus jeune âge tous les moyens
sont bons le jeu on amène les enfants à
communiquer à s'exprimer pia a progressé
dans tous les domaines ya atmosphère
plus studieuse chez les grands
aujourd'hui un terreau sur les vacances
encore maîtrisé l'oral puis les syllabes
pour aller progressivement vers
l'écriture
en attendant on travaille la motricité
on s'éveille au bout les enseignants eux
observent leur mission c'est aussi
déceler d'éventuels problèmes scolaires
familiaux ou même de santé là il ya un
travail plus spécifique on voit la
psychologue pour voir où on en est
voire si besoin d'un suivi à l'extérieur
d'orthophonie sous de psychomotricienne
ou plus quand on fera 10 des difficultés
l'égalité des chances se joue donc dès
la maternelle et qui sont un rêve très
simple et commentent est grande
comme ça